i married the best rapper of all time
a talented legit genius who gave me four
incredible kids so when i divorced him
you have to know it came down to just
one thing his personality
kim kardashian west had a ton of support
during her snl debut including from her
estranged husband kanye west that was
like such a fun time source tells etique
that quote kanye was in the audience
during her opening monologue and later
went backstage with all of the k names
it's really impressive that my mom
didn't pick karen i don't know how she
saw that one coming and not caitlyn
ahead of kim's highly anticipated
hosting debut et learned that she
bounced ideas off kanye for the gig it's
a really fascinating process you can't
help but wonder if this hilarious skit
where she's rapping about going to the
club when you're no longer in your 20s
was one of them
talk to them trish
i know you little girls ain't laughing
at me for your information i wasn't
asleep i was resting my eyes why are you
worried about me but now i'm wide awake
and
although the mother of four filed for
divorce from the rapper in february the
pair has remained friendly since and
were even spotted having dinner together
late last month well i'm suing kendall
because she has absolutely no drama
she won't cause any drama and it's
damaging our brand
i'm a jenner not a kardashian
and that's something you need to work on
honey kim k's mom kris jenner and sister
khloe kardashian got in on the fun too
and joined kim during her big moment
with a few cameos a source tells et
quote her family and friends are so
proud of her and thought she was
hilarious she felt supported by them and
feels confident in how she did it was so
nice for her to have her close friends
and family there cheering her on adding
that quote kim had an incredible time
hosting snl and is really happy with how
everything went i see on social media
that they're loving it and it really
inspires me also part of her support
group saturday was scott disick who was
photographed going to the snl after
party with khloe kardashian all of this
comes after scott allegedly sent eunice
benjamin another ex-boyfriend of
kourtney kardashians and instagram dm
dissing her pda filled romance with
travis barker which units posted online
it's like insane last month a source
told et that the scandal caused tension
between scott and courtney saying quote
courtney and scott are definitely not as
close as they once were scott has some
unsettled ill will towards courtney and
travis being together and courtney is
over the jealousy
well speaking of courtney and travis kim
didn't hesitate to poke fun at her
sister's relationship during the sketch
titled people's court baby
you're so epic oh you're so punk and
although court was not able to join in
on the festivities in person
she did give kim's performance a thumbs
up by posting this snapshot to her insta
stories writing quote kim kardashian you
killed snl i think you have to have a
sense of humor
[Music]
you